DAMIEN HENRY: Hello everyone.
My name is Damien.
And I feel very lucky today,
because two great artists,
Cyril Diagne and
Mario Klingemann
will join me on stage
in a few minutes
so you can see what they do
when they use machine learning.
So if you want to go to
the bathroom or text,
please do it while
I'm doing the intro.
But when they are there,
this is a really [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm working for the
Cultural Institute in Paris.
And the mission of
the Cultural Institute
is to help to a
museum, an institution,
to digitalize and to shared
their culture, their assets
online.
We are working with
more than 1,000 museums.
And it means that if
you want to discover
a new museum every week, it
will take you 20 years to do so.
What we do in the Cultural
Institute is this app.
It's named the Google
Arts and Culture App.
It's really a beautiful app.
And if you have not
downloaded yet, you should do.
There are a ton of really
incredible features.
And one of my favorites
is named Gigapixel.
Gigapixel is done
using the art camera.
And the art camera
is able to catch
every detail in a painting-- so
every crack, every blue stuff,
you can see them in the app.
You can zoom in very
deeply in the app, to see,
for instance, "Starry Night."
But I'm not working on this app.
I'm working in a
space named The Lab.
It's in the middle of Paris.
It's a beautiful space.
I feel lucky every
day when I go there.
And it's a space
dedicated for creativity.
And just as a fun fact, it's
where the Cardboard is born.
David Coz and I
use a laser cutter
there to create the very first
Cardboard-- the one that was
unveiled at I/O two years ago.
That's what I have
to show today.
And last year, we also
worked at the lab,
for instance, on this picture.
You can see some early
prototype of the Cardboard
that was unveiled at
I/O Google last year.
But here for the
Cardboard today,
even if I have still a strange
relationship with the VR team,
I also have a small team in
Paris that's is named CILEx.
It stands for Cultural
Institute Experiment Team.
And what we do,
we do experiments
with creative
[INAUDIBLE] and artists.
We are very passionate
about three different axes.
We try to engage more
people to enjoy culture.
So we try to find fun ways for
people to watch more paintings.
We try to find also a new
way to organize information.
So our user can have a
journey in our database,
and [INAUDIBLE] can learn
something out of it.
And obviously, because we
have seven million assets
in the database,
we try to analyze
them to discover new insights.
So this talk is about
machine learning, obviously.
And just take 30 seconds to
remind of the definition.
Just to make things
simple, let's imagine
that you are
writing an algorithm
to check if a picture
is a cat picture.
You can do it
yourself, by trying
to analyze all the pixels
one by one, but obviously,
it's difficult. Or what you can
do is, using machine learning,
having an algorithm that
will learn by itself
what are the good
features to check
if a picture is a cat picture.
So the key, I think, is
this is happening now.
Machine learning
is not the future.
Machine learning is something
that everybody in this audience
can do, can try.
If you know how to code, you
can try machine learning.
For example, did
you know that you
can create some "Mario Brothers"
levels just using a [INAUDIBLE]
networks.
Or you can make a color
movie from a black and white.
Or you can make a 3D
movie from a 2D movie.
So things that seem
difficult or impossible
are something that you can
do now using machine learning
and neural networks.
And as an example, this one
is "Inside the Brother."
It's David R from Japan,
designer and artist.
And he just decided to
make these simple games
with two volley players.
And in fact, they play
extremely well just
using a very, very
simple neural network
that he displays on the screen.
So because machine learning is
so useful and widespread now,
there is no doubt that it
will have a huge impact
on art and on artists.
So that's why we decide
something like one year
ago to create a machine
learning residency in the lab.
So we asked artists to join us
and to create great experience.
So now I will leave to Mario
Klingemann with our latest
artist in residence.
MARIO KLINGEMANN:
Thank you, Damien.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everybody.
My name's Mario Klingemann.
And I'm a code artists.
And might sound like I'm kind
of really good at indentation
or write beautiful code.
But that's not
really what it is.
It just says that I'm using
code and algorithms to produce
things that look interesting.
And some of them might
even be called art.
I don't know-- I'm not
the one to decide that.
Like any other artist,
I have this problem.
You look around you, and
it looks like everything
has already been done.
I mean, in times of Google,
you come up with a great idea,
you Google it, and think,
oh, well, OK, done already.
So it seems there are no
empty spaces anymore--
no white spaces where
you can make your mark,
where you can kind
of be original.
On the other hand,
if you look at it,
there are no real-- humans
are incapable of having
original ideas.
Ideas are always just
recombination of something
some other people
have done before.
You take concept
A and constant B,
and the idea is finding a
new connection between them.
And so this is where, for
me, the computer can help
me finding these connections.
So in theory, all
I have to do is
go through every
possible permutation.
And the computer will offer
me new combinations that,
hopefully, not have been done.
And all I have to
do is sit back,
and let the whatever
it has created pass by,
and decide if I like it or not.
So in a way, I'm becoming more
of a curator than a creator.
I'll show you a short example.
So this is a tool I call Ernst.
It's a kind of an homage
to Max Ernst, an artist
famous for his surreal collages
back in the early 20th century.
And what he did, he created
these collages from things
he found in papers, and
catalogs, et cetera.
So I decided, well, maybe I'll
build my own collage tool.
And in this case,
I'm using assets
found in the vast collection
of public domain images
by the Internet Archive.
And I wrote me a tool that
helps me to automatically
cut them out.
And then I say, OK, if I give
you these five elements, what
can you do with them?
And then it produces
me stuff like these.
And unlike Max Ernst,
I have the possibility
to also scale material.
And then you get these.
If you have like pipes,
you get fractal structures,
things that look like plants.
And the process
is very like this.
I have this tool with
all the library elements,
and then it just starts
combining them in random ways.
And sometimes, I see
something that I like.
Very often I see things
that are just horrible,
or just total chaos.
But yet, sometimes there's
something that looks like this.
I call that, for example,
"Run, Hipster, Run."
And I must say, coming
up with funny titles
or very interesting titles
is, of course, a nice perk
of this way of working.
But of course, there's
still this problem
that I still have to look
through a lot of images which
are just noise, just chaos.
So wouldn't it be nice
if the machine could
learn what I like, what my
tastes are, or, even better,
what other people like.
And then I can sell them better.
So I realized I have
to first understand
what do humans find
interesting in images?
What is it that makes one image
more artful than another one?
And this directed my view
to this growing amount
of digital archives.
And those are now-- there are
lots of museums and libraries
out there that start
digitizing all their old books
and paintings, just like
the Cultural Institute
helps museums doing that.
And so I first stumbled upon
this about two years ago,
when the British Library
uploaded one million images
that were automatically
extracted from books spanning
from 1500 to 1899.
There was only a little
kind of a problem with it,
because all these
illustrations and photos
were cut out automatically.
So they had OCR
scans, and then they
knew there would be an
image in a certain area.
But unless you didn't look
yourself at the image,
you wouldn't know
what's actually on it.
So if you were
looking for, let's
say, a portrait of
Shakespeare, you
would have to manually
go through every image
until you maybe struck upon it.
So I thought that's
a bit tricky.
Maybe I can help them with
classifying their material,
and training the computer.
OK, this is a portrait.
This is a map.
So I started in a way figuring
out ways how I could do that.
And eventually,
I was able to tag
about 400,000 images for them.
I mean, this was a
kind of group effort.
Everybody could join in.
But working with this
material, I realized,
is such a joyful experience,
because in the beginning,
I was just interested
in the machine learning.
But actually, you
suddenly realize
there's this goldmine,
this huge mine of material.
And sometimes, really,
you go through lots
of things that seem to be boring
or you're not interested in.
And then you strike upon
a beautiful illustration
or something.
And I realized that is
actually a huge part
of the fun of the process.
So for example, take
this rock or stone axe.
Well, once you go
through this material,
you start recognizing patterns.
And so sometimes there
comes this rock by.
And you say, OK,
well, I don't care.
But then the second one,
and you say, oh, maybe I
should start at a rock
collection or rock category.
And then what
happens is, suddenly
you are happy when every time
you come another one of those.
And then, well,
what I do is I start
arranging them, and putting
them kind of in a new context.
And then you start
actually starting
to appreciate the craftsmanship
that went into this.
And also you can-- once you
put lots of very similar things
together, you can much
better distinguish
between the slight
differences in there.
Yes, so I start doing this.
For example, here
on the left side,
you see a piece called
to 36 anonymous profiles.
There's all these 100s, 1,000s
of geological profiles, which,
again, you probably, if
you're not interested or are
a geologist, you wouldn't care.
But like this, it becomes
a really interesting field
or just a way to bring these
things that maybe sometimes
have been hidden for
100 years in a book,
and nobody has watched them.
And now you can bring
them back to life.
Or on the right side, a piece
I call "16 Very Sad Girls."
Again, I don't
know why they have
so many sad girls in there.
But of course, again, that
makes you question what
was happening at that time?
So it actually motivates
you to search back
and, well, what's the
story behind this?
But this all I started
kind of on my own.
And this was not-- I
wouldn't say it wasn't
deep learning what I was doing.
It was more classical
machine learning.
Because I was always
a little bit afraid
of going down this path.
I heard, oh, you need
expensive machines.
And it's kind of hard
to set up the machine.
So I needed something to
get me motivated to go
through the painful process of
installing everything to get
a machine learning system.
Luckily, about a year
ago, this came along.
I don't know if you
have seen this picture,
but when I saw it,
thought, oh, my god.
This looks kind of weird, and
I have never seen this before.
Fortunately, about a week
later, after this leaked,
it was clear some
engineers at Google
had come up with this new
technique called Deep Dream.
And it's based on
machine learning.
So of course, I wanted to
know how can I do this myself?
Fortunately, what they
did-- they actually
shared an IPython
Notebook on GitHub,
with all the source code,
even the trained model.
And it was able to
dig myself into this.
Back in the days, there
was no TensorFlow flow yet,
so this was still in Caffe.
But this allowed me to finally
kind of go by baby steps
into learning this technique.
And obviously, I started--
like probably a lot of us--
I started to having a
lot of fun with this.
You put in an image, and
you wonder, oh, my god,
what I get out of this?
Because that's what it is.
You put something in.
You had no idea
what you would get.
So this was fun for,
let's say, a few weeks.
But then I started
thinking, OK, I
think I could make some
improvements to this code.
And I would call
this Lucid Dreaming--
so maybe get a little bit more
control or change the outcome.
So I figured out
there are three points
I might be able to turn it
into a different direction.
So the first one-- I'm not
sure if you noticed it--
these pictures all kind of
a bit psychedelic, colorful.
So I'm from Germany.
We are kind of very
earnest people,
so I like it rather
a bit toned down.
So very simple thing--
desaturated a bit.
And desaturation is super easy.
So all I needed was to add a
single line of code, which is
the one you see at the bottom.
What you do is you take the
average between the RGB values.
And then you can have
a linear interpolation
between the gray-scale
version and the color version.
And depending on how
crazy you want it,
you pick a factor in the middle.
And so as an example
here, on the left side
psychedelic Mario, on the right,
the puppy face gray-scale one.
So the second thing--
that issue that you
don't know what
you will get out,
or when you get
something out, it
will be a selection of
slug, puppy, or eye.
So can I get a little
bit more control?
Well, in order to
do that, we have
to have a look at
how this thing works.
So this is the classic
convolutional network, which
is the Google Net in this case.
That was also the
architecture that
was used for the early
Deep Dream experiments.
So what you do,
you put something
in on the left--
an image-- and it
passes through all these
convolutional layers,
and soft Max.
Well, we don't go
into depth there.
In the end, you get out what the
machine thinks-- a probability
for certain categories.
What Deep Dream does is, you put
in an image at the beginning.
But then, instead of going
all through all the network,
you stop at a certain layer.
And at that layer, there are
certain neurons activated.
So depending on what the
network thinks it sees there,
some neurons will get
activated and others will not.
And what it does is
then it emphasizes
those activations even more,
and sends it back up the chain.
And then this will,
in a way, kind of
emphasize all those elements.
Where it thought it has
discovered, let's say, a cat.
Then it will improve the
cattiness of that image.
If you look at this,
what actually happens
inside this network-- and
I'm coming from the kind of,
let's say, a pixel
arts background,
or I'm doing lots
of with bitmaps.
So I look at it this way.
Then it's actually
bitmaps all the way down.
So in the top
layers, you can still
see there is some
convolutions going
on that reminds
you of sharpening
filters or something.
The deeper you go down
the net, actually, it
gets more and more abstract.
But for me, even those dots
are still little bitmaps.
And then I can do
stuff with them.
I can increase the brightness,
reduce or enhance the contrast,
blur things.
Or what I also can
do-- I can treat it
like a brain surgeon in a way.
Like I poke in, and say,
OK, when I poke in here,
does the finger
wiggle or the toe?
And what I can do
then is, I can just
say, well, how about if
I turn every neuron off
instead of, maybe, for example,
the 10 most activated ones,
and send it back up?
The code to do that is,
again, rather simple.
So again, each of these
little bitmaps is-- well,
for me, it's a bitmap or it's
a little array of numbers.
So what I can do for
each of these cells,
I just sum up all
the pixels in there.
Then I sort them by how
much they summed up to.
And in the end, I just keep the
top 10, for example-- or if I'm
just interested in a single
category, the most activated
one-- and replace all
the other values with 0,
and send it back up.
What I get then is something
that looks like this.
So it's kind of just
reducing everything
to a single category the
network thinks to have seen.
And I like these, really,
because they are, again,
totally out of this world.
Some remind me of
organic patterns.
Sometimes you can see,
OK, this might have come
from an eye detector or so.
But definitely, it
doesn't contain any traces
of slugs or eyes again.
But of course, there's
still this other issue.
And I call it the PuppyLeak,
or rather, I kind of
reveal why are there
so many puppies?
Like why does Deep Dream
have such a love for puppies?
Well, the reason is
that their network--
the original network--
that was used
for the first
release of Deep Dream
was based on the ImageNet
Large Scale Visual Recognition
Competition, which is kind
of the Olympics of image
recognition.
And in 2014, what they did--
they added 150 new categories.
And it was all dog breeds.
So that old rule applies--
gerbil in, gerbil out.
So whatever you train it with,
that's what you will get.
So then I thought,
OK, maybe I just
have to train this network
with something else.
But then kind of new to
it, I heard these stories
that it takes four weeks
on a super-powerful GPU
to train a network.
And I'm a poor artist.
I can't afford an NVIDIA
rack with these things.
But then I came
across this technique
which is really astonishing.
It's called fine tuning.
And what it does
is, you can take
an already trained network,
for example, the Google Net.
And all you have to do is
to cut off the bottom layer.
And then you can retrain
it with new material.
And what happens is,
all the top layers
are pretty much the same, no
matter what you train it with,
because they look for
abstract elements like edges,
curvature, or things like that.
So that doesn't need
to be retrained.
So doing that, you can
take a trained network.
You feed in new images.
Instead of taking
four weeks, you
can train a network overnight.
And the way I do it--
well, I tried it with I
called it MNIST with a twist.
I in my works with
these archives,
I come across a lot of
these decorative initials.
And I thought, is there
a way I could actually
train it to recognize
A, B, C that
come in all different
kinds of shapes?
Well, I tried.
And I must admit, there is
a manual process involved.
Because what I have to
do is, the way I do it,
I really start folders
on my hard drive,
and go manually, and drag and
drop whatever I find in this.
Let's say, oh, another A.
I drop in the A folder.
I don't have to do this with
the thousands of images.
Actually, it turns
out I can just
start with-- it's enough to
take 50 for each category.
I'm pretty sure there are people
who know much more than me
about machine learning.
They say, oh, my god,
that will never work,
and it will totally overfit.
It doesn't matter.
Actually, it works.
So I start with just let's say
20 to 50 images per category,
and then train the network
using the fine-tuning technique.
I let it kind of
simmer for two hours,
so it gets a little bit
accustomed to the data.
And then I use this
to show me what
it thinks these letters are.
So I train it a bit.
I give it a bunch
of random images.
And it says, I think it's an
A. I say, no, it's not an A.
And then a B?
Oh, yes.
And actually, it gets
better and better.
Because what I do is,
whenever it finds something,
it gets added to
my training set.
And I can repeat this process.
And in order to kind of help
me with this process of saying,
yes/no, I realized that kind
of left-swipe right-swipe
is a real popular way to decide
if you are into a specimen
or not.
And it's actually
a super-fast way.
So I can go back and
forth, and in one hour
I think I can go through 1,000
images and say if it's correct
or not.
And as a result-- so
for example here, this
is stuff where it has correctly
recognized that it's an A.
And you can see, it's
really surprising.
It comes in so many
different shapes
that, well, it's just
amazing how powerful
these networks are.
Then sometimes, it gives
me something like this.
And I don't know.
It looks like a ruin to me.
So the machine said it's a
B. And then I said, no, hmm.
So I actually went to the
original scan in the book
to check it out.
And indeed, it is a B
So it's really magic.
And of course, if everything
you have is a hammer,
everything looks like a nail.
It start seeing
letters in everything.
So it gives me these things.
But again, it's beautiful,
so maybe something I
have not been looking for.
But of course, I was
about Deep Dreaming.
So this is then what
happens if I use this newly
trained network on material.
And you can definitely
see it takes
an entirely different twist.
It suddenly has this
typographic feel to it.
And another example-- not
sure if you recognize the lady
on the left and the right.
But it's actually
the Mona Lisa in,
let's say it has a
linocut aspect to me.
But yes, there's no more
puppies involved at all.
But OK, one more
thing-- Deep Dream
had this great opportunity
in the spring this year,
where the Grey Area Foundation
located in San Francisco
was doing a charity auction
to fund their projects.
And I was really honored
to be invited to contribute
some artworks there.
So I kind of ate my
own dog food and tried
to create something that is
not obviously Deep Dream.
So I created this piece
called "The Archimedes
Principle," which reminds me
of a ball floating in water.
But the one thing I didn't
mention yet is my residency.
And the reason is,
it just started.
But I can tell you, I feel
like a child in a candy store.
It's really amazing.
I have this huge amount
of data to play with.
I have kind of metadata.
I have super-smart
people-- much smarter
than me-- that I can ask
extremely stupid questions.
And I've already
started working,
but it's still something
I want to fine-tune.
But I also had the privilege
to see what Cyril was actually
doing there for a while.
And so, with no
further ado, let's
get Cyril onstage so he can
show you some awesome things.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CYRIL DIAGNE: Thank you, Mario.
Well, my name is Cyril Diagne.
And I'm a digital
interaction artist.
So a question I get often is,
what is a digital interaction
artist?
So it's actually very simple.
I try to create poetic
moments for people
when they are interacting
with digital systems.
And the process is
also fairly simple.
It basically boils
down to two steps.
One step is just
plain, really-- just
like a kid getting my
hands on some technology,
and playing without
any goal, just
for the pleasure of learning
new things and having fun.
And then sometimes, a
poetic outcome appears.
And what that lets you
do is, for example,
swing through the stars,
or having your face covered
with some generative masks,
or creating a video of people
dancing together,
and so on, and so on,
and other things that I've
been doing over the last years.
But you might be wondering, OK,
what about machine learning?
It turns out one year ago,
I didn't know anything
about machine learning.
It all started when
Damien came to me.
He asked me, hi,
Cyril, how are you?
I'm good, thanks.
How are you?
Not too bad.
And he asked me, what
can you do with seven
million cultural artifacts?
I had to stop for a moment.
What do you mean seven
million cultural artifacts?
What can I do?
He said, yeah, well,
the Cultural Institute
has been working
for several years
with thousands of partners.
We have this great database
with amazing content.
Well, what can you do with it?
Well, I really had to
stop, because those
are seven million opportunities
to learn something new
about a culture,
about some events--
really incredibly
high-quality content.
So in order not to panic,
I did what every coder
would do in this situation.
I [INAUDIBLE] all the assets and
plotted to them in a sine wave.
Because then, I did not have
to think about it anymore.
That was done.
And from there, well, I did
the most obvious things.
I started to plot them by
time, by color, by medium.
And, well, you find
some interesting things
along the way.
But you can't help
but think there's
got to be more-- all
this great material, all
this great technology--
there's got to be
more that we can get out of it.
And so this is where machine
learning came across.
Especially when you go
to Google every day,
doesn't take too long
until someone points you
to some amazing things.
And so one of the first
experiments that we did
is using a popular
technology now,
which is the machine
learning annotation.
So it's the
technology that allows
you to find the photos
that you took in the forest
by typing "trees," the photos
of my friend Tony, et cetera.
But what about the less
expected labels-- the labels
you would not think in the
first place to write down?
And what about less-expected
images as well--
images that you would not
expect to find anywhere there?
Well, we were curious as well.
So we sent it all
over to the service.
And when we got
the results back,
well, I fell off my chair.
I will show you.
Can we get onto the demo?
So basically, what
we can see here
is that we got back around
4,000 different unique labels.
And we had to spend hours.
It was too amazing.
The things that were detected
were really incredible.
Let's go over one example
that you would expect to work,
because it does, but in
quite an amazing way.
So let's look for horses.
There.
So as you can see, some
beautiful artworks of horse.
Let's just take this one, for
example-- beautiful painting
from Xia Xiaowan.
It's quite incredible,
because I don't
know how he got his
inspiration to picture horses
from this angle,
because I didn't even
know it was possible, or
how the machine managed
to detect that it was a horse.
But it does.
And, well, it's quite amazing.
And also, you get examples
after examples of, well,
really incredible
things like this,
for example, calligraphic
artwork of, again, a horse.
But that really goes toward
the abstract representation
from Yuan Xikun.
And again, a beautiful
artwork, but it quite blows
my mind that now algorithms
are capable of distinguishing
this much amount of
details in these images.
So unfortunately, I can't
go over all those examples.
But we are going to
release this online soon.
So please take a day off
to go through all of them,
because there are some
pretty amazing examples.
And we said, OK, now that we
realize it really works, what
about more tricky examples?
Like for example,
let's put something
that leans toward emotion,
like "calm," for example.
Let's have a look.
Calm-- there.
Yeah, there is this thing where
we didn't know what to expect.
When you click on the label and
when you look at the content,
indeed, yes, I see.
I understand your
reference, computer.
These are indeed calm sceneries,
beautiful landscapes-- yeah,
it's peaceful.
So as we went over
and over, we came
across also labels that we would
have not thought to write down.
Like for example,
one that I quite
like-- I didn't know
it was a thing--
but we found this "lady
in waiting" collection,
automatically created, and
sent back by the algorithms.
But look at this
beautiful collection
of incredible artworks
from various centuries of,
I don't know, maybe--
I guess it was
a thing-- "Lady in Waiting."
Oh, well, apart from
that one, maybe.
And then maybe one last
example-- this one I really
fell off my chair.
I had no idea what to expect.
I was, like, that
must be some glitch.
But then when it appeared,
well, it just makes sense.
Yeah, I mean-- that's right.
So yes we'll release
this online soon.
We have to polish
a few things first.
But what you can see is
before the neural net is
able to label all
these images, first
he is representing all the
images in highly dimensional
world, let's say.
But it really
qualifies as the world.
Basically, the neural net, to
be able to apply those labels,
he positions every assets
at a particular position
in this world.
Well, I don't know about you,
but I want to visit that world.
What does it look like?
Is there an island of the
Impressionists with blue hats,
or the highway of Roman statues?
I don't know, but what I
suggest is you hop on with me,
and we just have a quick tour.
I will give you a quick tour.
OK, so let's start from
these two assets here.
Well, they seem
to have in common
that they are a landscape.
But let's take a step back.
We can see other artworks
appearing with, well,
it looks like some series of
landscapes-- more landscapes.
But if you look
around, then we can see
that we're actually surrounded.
We literally woke up in this, I
don't know, the Island of Art.
And well, let's have
a tour, actually.
So here we can see a scene
with animals, I guess.
As we continue, I think
it's this direction.
So let's give it a little
while for it to load.
People start to
appear in the picture,
along with those animals.
And if we step back
even more, actually,
let me take you to one
of my favorite spots
directly-- this one.
I call it "The
Shore of Portraits."
Look at this.
Let's give it a
little while to load.
And so this-- sorry,
I'm going really quick,
because we have a lot of
things that I want to show.
But this is a TSNE Map.
So TSNE stands for T-distributed
Stochastic Neighbor Editing,
which basically thanks
all those 128 dimensions
and flattens it to
just two dimensions,
so that you can plot them, and
make it interactive, and easier
to travel across.
So here is a very
simplistic diagram
that shows how you
can create the map.
So basically, we take the image.
We feed it into the
neural net which
extracts the raw features, which
is a 128 dimensional vector.
Then in two steps, we reduce
those dimensions to two.
And then it becomes-- you choose
the way you want to plug them.
But this you can do now
with eight lines of Python.
So it's not something
that is reserved
for scientists or researchers.
Thanks to some amazing open
source libraries like sklearn,
it is something you can do
with eight lines of Python.
You just load the CSV
of your raw features.
Well, I won't go
over all those lines,
but you do a truncated SVD,
which is the first [INAUDIBLE]
that reduces to 50 dimensions.
And then the TSNE is able
to create this nice map
of two-dimensional vectors.
And then, as we saw the
"Shore of Portraits,"
we got an idea,
which led to what
we call the "Portrait Matcher."
So basically, the
Cultural Institute--
we detected in the Art Project
Channel about 40,000 faces.
So the question came
quite naturally--
what if you could browse this
database with your own face?
And it has to be real time,
otherwise it did not happen.
So can we switch
back to the demo?
All right, let's try that.
Let's see if it works.
All right, so let's see.
Oh, wow, OK.
I think we might--
OK, so we still
have to polish this
one a little bit.
but if you come to
our lab in Paris,
we have a much refined setup,
which works much better.
But anyway, let's move on.
All right, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, can we switch
back to the slides?
All right, but one good thing
is that this experiment led us
to another iteration.
It came from another
popular thing that
happens is when you're
in front of a painting,
and you see someone drawn,
and you feel like, oh, I
feel like I know this person.
Or oh, that definitely looks
like my neighbor, Tony.
And actually, as
it turns out, there
is this great model that's
been done by some researchers
at Google which
is called FaceNet.
And this model is
able to achieve
99.63% accuracy
on the label face
in the wild, which is
the academic de facto
for this type of research.
So basically this neural net
embeds in an Euclidean space
faces that are from
the same identity
closer together than faces
with dissimilar identities.
So basically, same people
are closer in this space
than different people.
And what it sends
you back, basically,
is, again, 128
dimensional vector
that represents the embedding.
And so we had to give it a try.
So who knows these guys?
OK, they're very
popular in Europe, too.
So we took them as
a starting point.
Let's try to find.
Let's see how well
this model performs.
But let's not include in the
mix other pictures of them,
because I'm sure it would
work, so that would be boring.
What if, instead,
we forced the system
to send us only pictures
that are paintings?
Well, again, I can tell
you when I saw the result,
I fell off my chair.
And yes, I did spend a
lot of time on the ground
during this residency.
OK, I'm really excited to
press this next button.
All right, this is
what we got back.
I mean, Jared in the
middle-- even though there
is a huge-- I mean, there
is a gender mismatch-- that
could be his sister, right?
Or even Richard Hendricks,
just on the right of him, like,
it even got the
curliness of the hair.
It is just amazing.
So of course, you can
imagine from there
how many tries we did.
Everyone wants to find his
doppelganger in the database.
And here, who would have known
that Richard Hendricks had
in half-naked man painted at
the Tate Britain right now?
Let's take these
guys, for example--
some of my personal heroes.
Let's see what we get.
And there, again-- even
though this beautiful artwork
from Shepard Fairey for
Obama campaign in 2008
is highly stylized
with only four colors,
the algorithm still managed
to find the matching.
And yes, that is quite amazing.
It would have not been fair
not to try it with ourselves.
So we gave it a try here
at I/O. And sorry, Mario,
but-- [LAUGHTER] the
blue suits you so well.
So this is really fun.
And thanks again, for
Damien and everyone
at the Cultural
Institute for offering us
this really great opportunity.
And I will hand it
over to you again.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
DAMIEN HENRY: Thank you, Cyril.
Thank you, Mario.
I'm very happy to
work with these guys.
And I'm very lucky, I guess.
So what's next?
So if you want to
stay in touch with us,
please download our app.
It's a way to keep
a link with you.
And our goal is to inspire you
to try machine learning, too.
So if you want to give it a
try, I recommend TensorFlow.
It's an open-source
framework, easy to start with.
As a tutorial, the one
done by Mr. Karpathy
is really, really good.
It really helps me
to understand what's
going on with machine learning.
And the Cultural Institute is
not the only team within Google
that is really passionate
about machine learning.
So for instance, there
is the MEI Initiative.
And this link is
really good reading.
So I encourage you to try it.
And the last one
is about the team,
named Magenta, completely
dedicated to generate art
using machine learning.
So thanks, you, thanks everyone.
and that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]